wie wenn Sie diese Bilder sehen wenn Sie
diese Schilderungen hören wie wie sollte
Deutschland die Ukraine militärisch
unterstützen
natürlich erstmal grausam ja und jeder
Krieg und jeder Tod der jeder verletzte
ist nicht hinnehmbar allerdings muss ich
widersprechen wenn ich höre dass man
weiteren Waffenlieferungen diesen
Konflikt lösen kann wir sehen es ja
aktuell das ist eher in der Eskalation
Stufe die die Russland dazu führt dass
gerade was sogenannte neue Waffensysteme
die an die Ukraine geliefert werden wo
auch auf Russisch Gebiet geschossen wird
bzw wo natürlich auch eine Gegenreaktion
erfolgt und auf jede Reaktion folgt auch
eine Gegenreaktionen das sehen wir damit
wird der Konflikt nicht befriedet oder
beendet sondern er wird verlängert und
das ist genau das wovor wir immer
gewarnt haben das weitere
Waffenlieferung für eine Verlängerung
dieses Krieges führen und das sehen wir
jetzt weil sie sagen gerade da finden
Angriffe der Ukraine auf russisches
Territorium statt auch und deswegen
schlagen die dann so zurück das ist die
Idee wir haben es ja erlebt das Angriffe
auf die Krimi auf die Infrastruktur auch
war die Brücke genau was noch ja aber
das sind doch das wird natürlich auch
eine Gegenreaktion von Russland erfolgen
Angriff der auf dieses Gebiet erfolgt
erzeugt natürlich auch eine
Gegenreaktion und deshalb muss es so
schnell wie möglich um ein
Waffenstillstand und auch im
Friedensgespräche gehen das muss der
Ansatz für Diplomatie und auch für
Politik sein und das vermisse ich und
Gott sei Dank reden wir mittlerweile
mehr darüber das muss ich schon sagen
ich hoffe auch dass dort wirklich auch
die Bemühungen stärker erfolgen es gibt
friedenspläne es gibt auch gab auch ja
schon Friedensverhandlungen auch ein
Friedensplan der im Übrigen schon im
April vorlag der aber auf Betreiben der
Engländer wieder obsolet wurde bzw der
ja das hat auch Herr Kujat in mehreren
Interviews bereits mehrfach auch
geäußert z.B auf NTV wo genau das gesagt
hat dass dieser Friedensvertrag
vorgelegen hat und das auf Betreiben
Großbritanniens in dem Herr Johnson in
der nach gereist ist okay sozusagen auch
verhindert hat also hier sehen wir das
ist auch nicht von den Amerikanern und
die Briten gewollt ist dass dieser
Konflikt beendet wird jetzt verstehe ich
diesen Satz von ihnen der Krieg ist auf
beiden Seiten schrecklich
ja jeder Tote aber man sieht das ernst
diesen Satz
schrecklich natürlich es geht mir um ist
auf beiden Seiten
bestätigt das ist auch kriegsverfahren
kennen Sie die aus Russland solche
Bilder
Krieg ist doch ähnlich aufgebaut der
Angriff aufnehmen Irak auf Afghanistan
auf Syrien nicht das Thema Moment da gab
es noch die gleichen Bilder diese Bilder
und das jetzt auf die Infrastruktur
Angriffe gestartet werden das ist
natürlich in Grund warum man natürlich
auch die die das ähm ja die den
Widerstand der Ukraine brechen will
das ist leider Kriegs Rhetorik der
Russen die natürlich auf die
Infrastruktur jetzt gehen und das sollen
wir jetzt dann so laufen lassen
natürlich nicht ich ich
muss wirklich sagen ich erschüttert das
und ich verurteile das auch ganz klar
niemand von uns nach AFD würde sagen
ganz klar wer Täter und der Opfer ist in
dieser Geschichte das ist jetzt klar
geworden in den letzten zwei Minuten
sondern das ist auf beiden Seiten dass
dieses relativierende die sind die
kleinen Verantwortung nein ich sage
trägt die Verantwortung für diesen Krieg
die Verantwortung für diesen kriegt
Russland diese Angriff aber dieser Krieg
hat mehrere Väter ganz klar und die
Ursachen sind auch am besten zu suchen
zu ihnen also ich glaube ich würde das
mal faktisch klarstellen dass wir diese
Bilder diese Raketenangriffe in der
Ukraine sind und nicht in Russland es
gibt keine keine Angriffe der Ukraine
die russische Städte platt machen und
die russische Infrastruktur zerstören
das ist nicht die gibt es nicht und
Gebiet und ich möchte auch nochmal
darauf hinweisen dass die Krim
völkerrechtswidrig annektiert worden ist
von Russland das ist meines Erachtens
ukrainisches Gebiet und kein russisches
Gebiet
ich möchte mal mit diesem Mythos
Verhandlungen aufräumen Verhandlung gibt
es seit 2014 genau
wir müssen also nach Verhandlung zu
rufen ist außerdem so eine Binse
natürlich Ende der Krieg irgendwann mit
Verhandlungen aber er wird Enden auf der
Basis der militärischen Ergebnisse das
heißt so wie der Krieg endet wird der
Frieden sein und deswegen ist es
entscheidend in welchem militärischen
Situation die Länder sind das ist das
erste also natürlich gibt es irgendwann
Behandlung das heißt es gibt Verhandlung
auch jetzt es gibt Verhandlung der über
die Türkei es gibt verhandeln über die
VM
es gibt Gespräche mit zwischen Russland
und den USA aber was wir glaube ich ganz
klar anerkennen müssen ist das Russland
kein Interesse an diesem Verhandlungen
hat Russland hat gesagt es führt
Verhandlungen wenn seine eigenen
Bedingungen erfüllt sind das heißt z.B
dass die eine Aktion der viel Gebiete
anerkannt wird das ist dann aber keine
Verhandlung das ist eine Kapitulation
und ein Diktat Frieden
es gab die Verhandlung mit den
Istanbuler Community wo die Ukraine
weitreichende Zugeständnisse gemacht hat
wo die Ukraine beispielsweise Ende März
angeboten hat dass sie auf den
NATO-Beitritt verzichten würde dass man
über den Status der Krim 15 Jahre
verhandeln würde und weitere Sachen
Russland ist darauf nicht eingegangen
nach diesem Istanbuler Community ist es
der Ukraine gelungen die russischen
Truppen zurückzudrängen und die
Kriegsverbrechen in Butcher und in ihren
sind bekannt geworden und mariupel ist
von den Russen erobert worden und damit
war auch klar dass alles was russisch
besetzt ist das unter russischer
Besetzung Kriegsverbrechen stattfinden
und damit war auch für die Ukraine klar
das mögliche Verhandlungen eigentlich
eine Preisgabe der eigenen Bevölkerung
gewesen wären
das heißt es wird immer so suggeriert
wenn wir jetzt aufhören mit dem Krieg
dann ist unter der russischen Besetzung
Frieden das ist es aber nicht wenn sie
sich angucken was unter russischer das
können sie ganz klar sehen bei den
Bildern aus Butcher und irrtin bei den
Berichten über die Kriegsverbrechen in
easium bei den Bildern die wir aus
rachson sehen wo es auch Berichte über
Kriegsverbrechen und Verbrechen in der
Zivilbevölkerung gibt wo es einen ganz
klare Beweise für die was ich vorhin end
ukrainisierungspolitik genannt habe
Verstärkung von Kindern verbieten
der ukrainischen Sprache Auslöschen der
ukrainischen Kultur das heißt für die
Ukraine ist die Lehrer das gebiete die
Russisch besetzt sind
sie eigentlich ihre eigene Bevölkerung
Kriegsverbrechen freigibt und nochmal zu
ihren Russisch zu den verhandlungssachen
Russland sagt immer sie möchten
verhandeln aufgrund wenn man ihre eigene
Bedingungen erfüllt also Anerkennung der
Annexion von 20 Prozent also keine schon
Territorium sie machen keinerlei
Vorschläge was solche Verhandlungen sein
sollten und deswegen muss man sich
glaube ich so ein bisschen davon
verabschieden natürlich gibt es
irgendwann Verhandlungen
implizierter dass die andere Seite
Interesse daran hat und Russland zeigt
kein Interesse an Verhandlungen es zeigt
Interesse an einer Kapitulation und an
einem Diktat reden das sind keine
Verhandlung das heißt 20% des eigenen
Territoriums und der eigenen Bevölkerung
Opfern und das nachdem wie die Bilder
von
ishium-pin gesehen haben geht nicht was
ist bevor wir vielleicht noch mal
aufmachen wenn Sie diese Bilder aus
Botschaft hat noch mal sehen was ist
Putin für sie ist das ein
Kriegsverbrecher oder was ist das
ich sehe in diesem Zusammenhang was
bringt uns jetzt Herrn Putty als
Kriegsverbrecher zu titulieren bringt
einen weiter wissen sie haben
amerikanische Präsidenten eben du
Kriegsverbrecher sind wenn ich diesen
Job es war nicht die Frage doch Moment
ich sehe diese Doppelmoral die die Moral
bin ich immer bereit zu sprechen
in dem Fall aktuell bringt uns doch die
Definition Kriegsverbrecher ist ja oder
nein in keiner Weise weiter doch nein
doch woran dass wir uns moralisch gut
fühlen und nein nein nein nein nein nein
bitte mit was denn dann die Frage ob
jemand ganz klar
Kriegsverbrecher ist oder nicht das hat
doch im Zweifel dann auch konsequent
sind
sie ja gut bin ich natürlich wenn jemand
dann Kriegsverbrecher heißt ja
Kriegsverbrechen begeht genau dann hat
das doch Konsequenzen völkerrechtlich
und das muss natürlich geahndet werden
ist dieser Mann Kriegsverbrecher für
mich ist ja kein Kriegsverbrecher warum
nicht ja wie gesagt weil wir das nicht
als ich habe das nicht zu beurteilen ob
er ein Kriegsverbrecher ist das müssen
zuständige Gerichte nach dem Krieg
machen okay Butcher war ein
Kriegsverbrechen das kann ich noch nicht
beurteilen ist auch nicht ausgewertet
komplett Angriff auf zivile
Infrastruktur ist ein Kriegsverbrechen
wissen Sie auf diese auf diese
Definition gehe ich überhaupt nicht ein
ja nein es muss sich auch nicht
natürlich ist ein Angriff es ist es zu
echten und ob das völkerrechtlich ein
Kriegsverbrechen ist wie gesagt jeder
Krieg ist für mich verstehen wo sie da
stehen okay und und das muss natürlich
aufgeklärt werden und wenn es
Kriegsverbrechen gibt die Soldaten im
übrigen ausführen und durchführen dann
müssen die verurteilt werden und dann
müssen die natürlich auch zur
Rechenschaft gezogen werden und diese
Kriegsverbrechen okay
so schwer fällt welche amerikanische
Präsident ist dann Kriegsverbrecher wir
haben doch die äh die haben noch die in
den äh die Angriffskriege auf Irak
gesehen
doch nicht verurteilt ne leider nicht ja
genau
hatten also sie wollten damit andeuten
das sind ja Soldaten die die Leute
umbringen es ist ja nicht gut im
persönlichen Befehle gegeben hat und für
diese Kriegsverbrechen was aufgeklärt
werden muss da muss er natürlich genauso
verurteilt werden und das gilt genauso
wie die amerikanischen Präsidenten das
gilt genauso für den Angriff auf den
Irak wo im übrigen und das ist bei
George ist auch nicht verurteilt das ist
ja weil sie auch nicht in der Konvention
mit beteiligt sind USA China und
Russland beteiligen sich daran nicht
also wird es auch schwierig sein
interessante Verurteilung von Herrn
Putin als Kriegsverbrecher gehen die
wird es nicht geben warum diskutieren
wir darüber überhaupt das ist der Punkt
noch mal kurz zum Iran sie werden
jederzeit mit mir bereit zu diskutieren
darüber dort stabile Busch dann
Kriegsverbrechen nicht auch mit ihm
natürlich aber fangen wir doch erstmal
an was in den Vergangenheit passiert ist
warum wurden diese Dinge nicht
aufgeklärt warum wurden diese
Präsidenten nicht zu Verantwortung
gezogen das ist doch der Punkt
[Musik]
unterbrochen
ich wollte nur den Punkt machen dass sie
an der einstelle gesagt haben ob Putin
ein Kriegsverbrecher ist das könnten
erst Gerichte in dem Fall wäre es wohl
Den Haag beurteilen aber den
amerikanischen Präsidenten bezeichnen
sie als Kriegsverbrecher und dann ist es
bestimmt auch so dass man das natürlich
solange der Krieg läuft ist noch keine
Urteile gibt aber man muss ja nur sich
die Schilderungen von den Menschen
anhören die dort in den Gebieten sind
die die Dinge erlitten haben also wir
haben zum Beispiel einen Reporter der
dort vor Ort war die Menschen interviewt
hat sich die Geschichten angehört hat
mit einem Fotografen unterwegs hat die
Schicksale fotografiert hat und das was
augenscheinlich ist das sind natürlich
Kriegsverbrechen da hat die Frau mallor
vollkommen Recht und davor kann man ja
nicht die Augen verschließen man kann ja
nicht sagen dass man das einfach laufen
lässt und dann guckt man wenn es mal zu
Ende ist wer da vielleicht noch lebend
rausgekommen ist und versucht dann in
irgendeiner Form Beweise zu sichern und
das geschieht ja jetzt auch im Moment
schon dass
international die Beweise gesichert
werden und es gibt genug Beweise um auch
unjuristisch sagen zu können dass dort
Kriegsverbrechen geschehen sind und ich
halte es wirklich für
unmenschlich und
unverantwortlich einfach zu sagen das
sind keine kriegsverbreche und sich da
auf eine ja und doch tatsächlich gesagt
Position zurückzuziehen und vor allem
anderen die Augen zu verschließen das
ist einfach nicht haltbar vielleicht
kannst
das würde bedeuten dass Großmächte
sie schwer zu verurteilen sind nie
Kriegsverbrechen begehen weil man ihre
Führer nie vor ein Gericht stellen kann
das ist ja ein Zirkel Schluss was wir
wirklich brauchen und sie haben was sie
aufgedeutet was sie angedeutet haben und
das halte ich für richtig wir brauchen
dringend ein Tribunal das neben dem
Internationalen Gerichtshof dem
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof auch
darüber beurteilen kann dass der gesamte
Krieg ein Angriffskrieg ist und illegal
was wir hier sehen ist ja nicht nur nur
unter Anführungszeichen weil es
unsägliches eine Zerstörung eines Landes
die übrigens offen angekündigt wird das
was Putin und seine Politiker und auch
seine Generäle und seine Apologeten im
russischen Fernsehen erklären es ist ein
Vernichtungskrieg der die Ukraine von
der Landkarte auslöschen soll als Stadt
als Identität ukrainische Elite ist
Faschismus so wird das in Russland seit
Monaten präsentiert und das heißt es ist
eigentlich ich würde sagen es sieht
schon sehr stark nach einem Völkermord
aus und es ist ja doch sehr interessant
dass gerade diese nächste Woche der
Deutsche Bundestag einen von Stalin in
der Ukraine begangenen Völkermord 1932
den hollodon Hunger tot durch Hunger
verurteilt während in Russland die
Rehabilitierung von Stalin genau diesem
Mann unter Wladimir Putin immer neue
Höhen erreicht jetzt wird schon
diskutiert Wolgograd wieder in
Stalingrad umzubenennen ich war in
Moskau habe gesehen wie Stalin in den
Museen schon 2014/15 wieder
rehabilitiert wurde wir haben also hier
eine klare Kontinuität eine klare
Ideologie das ist die Ideologie eines
Vernichtungskrieges gegen ein Volk gegen
einen Staat wir sehen es täglich und ich
verstehe nicht wie man in Deutschland
sitzen kann mit all dem was uns
glücklicherweise JournalistInnen
Journalisten aber natürlich auch die die
darüber als Flüchtlinge berichten sind
der Millionen Ukraine hier die Familie
haben wieder ständig erleben wie man da
sagen kann ich weiß nicht recht ob der
der für das alles verantwortlich ist
seit dem 24 Februar nichts davon gäbe es
ohne den Angriffsbefehl von Protein wenn
man da sagen kann
wir wissen nicht was los ist vielleicht
ist der Mann unschuldig das verstehe ich
nicht wir fanden sie in dem Zusammenhang
den Satz von Björn höcke das Russland
nach langem Zögern hart und konsequent
achtung auf die Offensive einer
raumfremden macht reagiert habe was ist
das eine Raumfrage kann ich nicht
beantworten schon fragen was er damit
gemeint hat die weiß nicht aus welchen
Kontext das gerissen ist aus welcher
Rede das gerissen ist kann ich nicht
beantworten weiß ich nicht das sind die
USA
ich meine dass die USA dort Kriegspartei
sind das ist ja nur offensichtlich das
sehen wir ja jeden Tag das die natürlich
sind die Amerikaner Kriegspartei in
diesem in diesen Konflikt ist in
Deutschland auch Kriegspartei ja wenn
wir weiter Waffen liefern vor allem wenn
wir direkt Panzerlieferungen an die
Ukraine liefern dann kann es durchaus
sein dass wir Kriegspartei werden davor
waren ja auch viele davon waren im
übrigen auch die Amerikaner und deshalb
finde ich ja auch gut in dem Punkt
zumindestens gut dass der Bundeskanzler
dort noch zählt hat
genießen ohne diesen Ring tausch das ist
ohne diesen Ringtausch direkt Lieferung
geben soll das kann uns in der Tat zur
Kriegspartei machen lassen und davor
habe ich Angst davor hat die Bevölkerung
in Deutschland Angst und das sollte
wirklich gut überlegt werden
noch mal juristisch noch mal weil ich es
gerne verstehen würde sie sagten gerade
Völkerrecht da sind sie absolut dafür
dass der gute Sache aber Völkerrecht
kann man noch nicht juristisch klären
das ist eine politische Einordnung
ist auch eine politikrecht im
Völkerrecht gibt es den definierter
Völkerrecht wer macht das wie groß muss
immer wieder benutzt wird ich wollte
auch was anderes machen im Völkerrecht
haben uns alle gemeinsam quasi drauf
verständigt als eine der Lehrerin aus
diesem jeder Angriffskrieg ist
völkerrechtswidrig nein nein ganz kurz
den Punkt machen der Punkt ist die
Unterstützung eines anderen Landes wenn
es um selbst Verteidigung ja das haben
wir mit unterzeichnet ja das damit
falsch ja Ukraine hat kein
Selbstverteidigungsrecht Ukraine ein
Selbstverteidigungsrecht aber wir können
aber wir haben keine Verpflichtungen zu
unterstellen müssen
verstehen ja wir haben aber nicht
sozusagen die Verpflichtung sie dabei zu
unterstützen sich selbst zu verteidigen
darum gehts also wissen Sie die Ukraine
ist wieder EU-Mitglied noch NATO
Mitglied von daher haben wir schon mal
vertraglich überhaupt keine
Verpflichtung haben wir nicht
Völkerrecht nein nur Moment wir haben
vertraglich keine Verpflichtung der
Ukraine zu helfen das ist schon mal Fakt
ja wir haben es getan
Helsinki 75 oh okay
das ist total interessant da saßen 75
lauter Menschen zusammen Anführer von
Staaten auch die Russen übrigens
die saßen da zusammen und hatten alle
alle die da saßen die Erfahrung des
Zweiten Weltkriegs in den Knochen und
haben vor dem Hintergrund dieser
grauenvollen Erfahrung gesagt was auf
das darf nie wieder passieren und auch
die Sowjetunion hat damals mit
unterschrieben die Souveränität eines
anderen Landes ist gefälligst zu
respektieren und zu achten zählt das
alles nicht mehr natürlich zählt das
aber man kann auch Entschuldigung man
kann den Zweiten Weltkrieg nicht mit
diesen Krieg vergleichen nein nein nein
ich rede jetzt von der Konsequenz daraus
von der Lehre die wir daraus geworden
die durchaus als Reaktion Atomwaffen in
Gebrauch nehmen kann und hat sie auch
angekündigt und deswegen helfen wir
nicht oder verstehe jetzt nicht ja
wollen wir ein Atomkrieg in Deutschland
in in Europa
dann wenn Deutschland Waffen liefert
seltsamerweise aber lieber die
Amerikaner was tun
ja da dieser Konflikt ist ja
mittlerweile wirklich so weit gediehen
dass es auf ganz Europa ausbrechen kann
und auch Europa mit natürlich
konzentrieren kann das möchte ich
verhindern
von Politik und nicht von Experten von
Politik das zu verhindern das ist meine
Aufgabe als gewählter Volksvertreter das
natürlich auf politischer Weise auf
Diplomat auf diplomatischerweise zu
verhindern und hier den in Konflikt zu
lösen und das geht nur am
Verhandlungstisch und umso eher desto
besser und das heißt wir hätten die
Ukraine und wenn am Ende und wenn am
Ende natürlich auch dort als Konsequenz
in Teilen Gebiete neutral bleiben so wie
sie mit Minions 2 Abkommen z.B auch klar
beschrieben haben wenn es den Frieden
dient warum nicht wenn es keine Toten
mehr gibt warum nicht ich glaube weil
2014 gezeigt hat dass der Deal Land
gegen Frieden nicht funktioniert hat
er nicht funktioniert
natürlich
am 24 februar von Russland auf die
Ukraine stattgefunden hat weil Russland
sozusagen die Lehre aus 2014 gezogen hat
ich führe einen Angriffskrieg ich
annektiere die Krim ich besetzte Teile
von dann jetzt und Johannes und ich
komme damit international durch wenn wir
das noch mal zulassen wenn wir jetzt
zulassen das Russland erfolgreich
völkerrechtswidrig viel Gebiete
annektiert und die Krim behält sind wir
sicherheitspolitisch in Europa
schlechter aufgestellt weil Russland
daraus die Lehre ziehen kann es
funktioniert ich kann mir weitere
Gebiete einverleiben plus wir haben eine
also da sind andere Länder wie Georgien
oder Moldau die nächsten auf der Liste
Russland drückt geographisch näher an EU
und NATO Territorium ran das heißt für
uns ist die sicherheitspolitische Lage
danach deutlich prekärer als jetzt und
ich ehrlich gesagt wir haben gerade eben
über Großmächte gesprochen das ist ein
Verständnis von Großmächte haben mehr
Rechte als die Kleinen und die kleine
haben halt Pech gehabt und das
widerspricht dem was sie eben
angesprochen haben mit der Helsinki
Schlussakte wo sich die Sowjetunion gut
die westlichen Staaten gemeinsam auf
bestimmte Prinzipien geeinigt haben wie
terituelle Integrität also ich
verschiebe keine Grenzen Souveränität
jeder kann selber entscheiden was er
machen will jedes Land freie bündniswahl
jeder darf selber entscheiden ob er EU
der NATO-Mitglied wird das hat die
sowjetun nicht nicht nur 75
unterschrieben das haben sie bestätigt
in der in der Karte von Paris 1990 und
in der NATO Russland Grundakte in den
90ern noch mal das heißt wenn wir
zulassen das Russland unter seinem
nuklearen Schirm erfolgreich einen
konventionellen Krieg führt sind wir in
Europa deutlich unsicherer und
international gibt es viele Staaten die
zugucken China beispielsweise die gucken
und sagen okay
anscheinend komme ich damit durch dass
ich unter meinem nuklearnschirm
konventionell mir andere Länder unter
Nagel reißen kann in Klammern Taiwan und
das ist ein internationales
ordnungsproblem
was ich für enorm gefährlich halte
letzter Punkt und das führt dazu
dass noch mehr Start nach Nuklearwaffen
greifen werden weil sie sich denken
die Ukraine hat keinerleihe Bestrebung
und hat keinerlei
nachweisenski hat das auf der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz
von Atomwaffen das ist aber was anderes
als eigener Erfahrung das ist die rote
Linie Thüringen gewesen die auch für
Putin klar überschritten war und das war
für ihn mit ein Grund äh in die Ukraine
Einzelzimmer
zwei Sachen zum Thema Atomwaffen die
Ukraine hatte ja mal Atomwaffen oder sie
dann abgegeben mit der Prämisse dass ihr
Staatsgebiet erlaubt wurde glaube ich
gerade in der Ukraine finden der nicht
sagen würde schade dass wir das gemacht
haben gebrochen worden übrigens
unterschrieben so ist es und die zweite
Sache zum Thema atombedrohung der Westen
hat sich ja von den Drogen Putins nicht
beeindrucken lassen jedenfalls nicht so
dass er wirklich zurückgezogen wäre und
keine Waffen liefert und dann die Frage
wollen wir Kriegspartei werden natürlich
nicht und trotzdem darf man so wie
gerade beschrieben die nukleare
Bedrohung nicht dafür nehmen dass man
sagt jeder der Nuklearwaffen hat kann
seinen Nachbarn überfallen und der Rest
der Welt schaut zu und Deutschland und
die Amerikaner und auch überhaupt die EU
und die Amerikaner sind sich da ja sehr
einig dass man in gewisser Weise
besonnen vorgeht so wie es der Kanzler
sagt dass man nicht
in der Art und Weise als Kriegspartei
Eintritt nicht aktiv schon mal gar nicht
mit boots on the ground sondern dass man
aber natürlich die Ukraine mit Waffen
unterstützen muss um auch die eigene
Sicherheit zu verteidigen auch wenn die
Ukraine nicht NATO Mitglied ist und
nicht EU-Mitglied ist
Putin hat sehr klar gemacht dass er das
alte so Wert reicht zurück haben möchte
und als nächstes kann man davon ausgehen
dass seine Truppen vor Polen und voll
Litauen stehen ja das sind nach und
Mitgliedern
Moment gegen den Westen gegen den Westen
führt ein hybridenkrieg ergreift unsere
freien Demokratien an indem er auch
das Information betreibt auch versucht
ihnen Klientel auf die Mühlen zu spielen
das möglichst viele Leute sagen man
sollte den Putin da mal in Ruhe machen
lassen und es fängt aber die Ukraine
heute haben Entschuldigung die Ukraine
war vorher auch schon keine freie
Demokratie also auch das stimmt doch
nicht
sein demokratisches System es gab
sicherlich es war sicherlich keine so
saubere und gute Demokratie also nicht
eine Demokratie in Reinform es gab auch
viel Korruption das wissen wir aber
lieber auf einem demokratischen Weg und
das ist immer deshalb ist
völlig egal
auf einem demokratischen Weg war Herr
Klaus
also zunächst glaube ich tatsächlich
dass das der Grund warum wir die Ukraine
unterstützen müssen ist nicht nur das
Völkerrecht das klar ist
angegriffen das ist in der Uncharted das
Grundprinzip dass man da sich
verteidigen darf und Hilfe bekommen darf
es ist auch nicht nur die Moral dass ihr
ein unsäglicher Krieg losgebrochen wurde
der vollkommen unnötig ist und
unglaublich viel Leidenschaft es ist das
deutsche oder europäische Interesse an
einer stabilen sicherheitsordnung denn
was ist die Ukraine jetzt dort
verteidigen ist nicht nur eigenes Land
sondern es ist auch das Grundprinzip das
all das was wir uns nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg Anordnung gegeben haben
irgendwie Bestand hat und es ist ja
nicht so dass Vladimir Pute nicht sehr
deutlich ausdrückt was ihn inspiriert er
weint St Petersburg vor allen Dingen
Monaten und hat ganz klar erklärt er
sieht sich in der Tradition von Zar
Peter dem Großen der 22-Jährige Krieg
geführt hat und Putin hat ausgeführt
Peter der Große der Zahl hat in diesen
22 Jahren russisches Territorium also
das Imperium
zurückgeholt und so sieht er sich und es
könnte ein Klarheit nicht wir könnten er
könnte uns das Niederschreiben er könnte
herkommen er könnte uns hier sagen ich
habe das Gefühl sie verhalten ein
bisschen so wie die kommunistischen
Führer stalinistischer Parteien in
Westeuropa in den 40er Jahren die egal
was Stadien damals gemacht hat immer
gesagt haben muss man verstehen wir
sehen keine Verbrechen und dann kann das
schreckliche Aufwachen
wir brauchen das nicht wir sehen jetzt
schon was passiert aber was muss
passieren damit sie von dieser ja dieser
Verteidigung eines Kriegsverbrechens in
einem Verteidiger das nicht naja sie
sagen Großmächte wenn sie sich
provoziert fühlen und Atomwaffen haben
können ein anderes Land angreifen mit
den Methoden die wir hier sehen man kann
sie dann nicht vor Gericht bringen das
heißt man kann sie nie als Verbrecher
bezeichnen sie enthalten sich ihres
eigenen Urteils und überhaupt sind die
anderen schuld und das ist doch relativ
die Schuldfrage habe ich gar keinster
Weise in irgendeiner Weise benannt und
darum
aber es geht doch darum dass wir auch
die Sicherheit
dieser Schuld hat mehrere Väter mehrere
Schulden gibt es nicht nein nicht er ist
nicht allein an diesem Krieg Schuld aber
er ist Schuld deine Mitschuld natürlich
hat er eine
mitschuldigung wissen Sie wer wir sind
auf dem Jahr beurteilen ja leider war
für mich ist es wichtig dass auch hier
die Sicherheitsinteressen aller Länder
auch Russlands müssen berücksichtigen
werden meiner Meinung nach zu wenig und
das haben wir auch zu wenig gemacht und
deswegen wurden auch die Minions zwei
Verträge wurden viel zu wenig
kontrolliert und Verständnis für das was
Putin macht Frage ich habe keinen
Verständnis wie das machen ich heiße
auch für irrational weil es wird in
keinster Weise in in dieser Weise
nachvollziehen nein ich ich ich kann ich
bin nicht in deinen Kopf drin ich kann
die denken wenn sie sagen dieser Krieg
hat mehrere Väter natürlich absolut ja
genau aber ganz klar die Amerikaner die
haben noch aktuell aber natürlich
aktuell haben die Amerikaner was hat z.B
der der Sohn der Sohn von beiden was hat
er die Jahre zu in der Ukraine gerade
mit der ukrainischen Regierung aktuell
die die an die Macht gekommen ist welche
welches Interesse und welche Dinge
wurden dort vorher auch sagen Sie es
doch genau welche ja dass man diese
diesen dass man diese diese Provokation
auch die Aussagen von selenski die an
allen weiten Teilen auf der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz ich habe es
angedeutet wo er ganz klar gesagt hat
dass er ihr atomare Aufrüstung möchte
dass in der NATO beitreten möchten
lassen die rote Linien die überschritten
worden
Entschuldigung Ukraine da Handarbeiten
ganz kurz kommt der beiden was ist die
Geschichte Hinterhand dabei erklären Sie
uns einmal ja das sollte uns der
amerikanische Präsident erklären
eigentlich macht in der Ukraine das
möchte wissen was macht der dort sagt
welche Firma hat er dort aufgebaut
welche Strukturen hat er aufgebaut
welche Option das haben sie angedeutet
welche ja das muss aufgeklärt werden
weil ja genauso mit in diesen Konflikt
drin steckt weil das die Provokationen
sind die Daten mit einer Ursache haben
für diesen Krieg weil bei beiden Sohn
dort gearbeitet
Zufall das war die Evokation nochmal die
Provokation ist gar nicht ich
Provokation ich nehme sie ganz ernst ich
ich cool ja wirklich also ich verstehe
ihren Punkt ich erlebe diesen dieses
Argument höre ich immer wieder wenn sie
durch Amerika reisen kommt das ständig
ständig sehen Sie Handarbeiten ja sehen
sie ist kein Argument dann kommt immer
auf Nachfrage kommt dann kann man ganz
schnell ist man dann im Keller einer
Pizzeria in Washington und so weiter das
ist dieses komische narrativ dieses
Raunen von irgendwas aber wenn man dann
konkret fragt sag jetzt mal bitte
Handarbeiten welche Rolle die Frage Sie
jetzt ganz konkret hat Handarbeiten dort
gespielt sicherlich keine gute Rolle ich
diesen Konflikt in irgendeiner Weise
entschärft das wissen sie alleins das
wird alles die Wahrheit kommt raus auch
nachtlichtig ja ich auch und dann wird
genau werden wir genau
ich vermute es was vermuten die
Vermutung Vermutung die ich nicht weiß
äußere ich aber sie rauchen diese
wunderbar
ja sprechen gerade von Vätern des
Krieges und dann sind
wer profitiert denn aktuell von diesem
Krieg am meisten
na ja also wenn sie einmal gewehrt hätte
kenne ich einen der hätte richtig davon
profitiert den aktuell profitiert davon
wirtschaftlich ganz klar sind die
Amerikaner und da muss man schon die
Fragen cool Wohnung wem nutzt es dieser
Krieg dieser Konflikt warum nutzt denn
das jetzt so das sehen wir doch aktuell
die Inflation ist in Amerika relativ
niedrig im Vergleich zur europäischen im
Vergleich zur Europäischen Union die
Energiepreise sind auf demselben Niveau
die steigen nur bei uns die Amerikaner
verkaufen uns für ein sieben acht neun
zehnfachen höheren Preis LG Gas also
davon profitieren Sie und Sie haben Nord
Stream zumindestens dahin gehen
wahrscheinlich äh die Finger mit im
Spiel sie glauben dass sie Amerikaner
die die Pipeline sabotiert gesprengt
haben das glauben sie müssen ich will
wissen wer es gesprengt hat und ich
hätte mir gewünscht aber schon wieder
dieses inselieren das ist die
amerikanische
Russen gewesen wäre hätten wir schon
lange gewusst